for decades the u.s congress has tried
and failed to reform the country's
immigration policies
the problem at the border is getting
worse but that has not diminished the
hopes or the numbers of people who want
to become
citizens of the united states dw's
carolina chamoy picks up
that part of the story
can you see by the door
10 000 new americans have been welcomed
all over the country
within the last week they have been
waiting for at least five years
for this very moment to happen this
celebration
took place at mount vernon the home of
the first u.s
president george washington russia
sudan 39 people from 32 different
countries are now americans
joshua green has served in the us army
since 2019
he's waited for five years to become an
american citizen
freedom i always say that freedom you
know
judging from where i come from to where
i am right now there's a big difference
when it comes to
freedom it comes to respect for human
life
when it comes to human rights and all of
those things
are things that are scarce anywhere
outside america
but in america it's something we enjoy
in abundance
so freedom is indeed the big thing but
i'm so
excited about being an american citizen
was born in vietnam a communist country
i used to be a communist party member
and i
renounce it so i joined this country and
the usa accepts me this country
have democracy and freedom
myself arrived six years ago with her
family from sudan
i am wait a long time to come to
citizenship thank you thank you so much
i am so happy now the number of
naturalizations has little to do with
the sitting president
and has always been that high it only
went down last year because of kovit
joseph sauer tells us
we're a nation of immigrants and we are
stronger
as a country as you when you bring in a
diverse and inclusive crowd from dip
from different countries and cultures
and it just makes us better
uh as a country an idea the united
states was built on
245 years ago
[Music]
well carolina chamoy joins me now from
washington good evening to you carolina
that was a powerful piece
there that you put together and you know
we just celebrated the fourth of july
independence day holiday in the u.s
it's america's birthday for the 400
million people
who are u.s citizens was it a birthday
party that
everyone felt invited to
well brenda so many things in this
country also the fourth of july was
quite a divided holiday many people had
barbecues of course and were celebrating
not just the fourth of july
but the easening of the covet
restrictions actually it seems
as if the pandemic is over here in the
united states because we saw large
gatherings
all around the country and of course the
traditional fireworks
also in washington dc president biden
and the first lady
jill biden watched the fireworks from
their balcony and had a
a huge dinner at the white house but
then brent we also learned today that
more than 180 people were killed
in shootings across the u.s over the 4th
of july holiday weekend
and this is the data published by the
gun violence archive
in total there were more than 540
shootings
over the holiday weekend in chicago in
texas in virginia and ohio
the shootings happened in large
gatherings drunk people
and of course the fact that it's easy to
access
guns in certain parts of this country
you know those
new americans in your story the
naturalized citizens do they have a
picture of their new homeland that
varies
fundamentally from the image those born
in the united states
seem to share
well the ones we talked to compare it to
their own country of origin
we just saw in the report of vietnam
sudan nigeria
comparing these countries to the u.s
they assured they would feel a sense of
freedom in the united states because
their countries have been riddled with
with corruption and and crime
i don't think um the perception of the
united states uh
varies that much between the new
citizens and and the ones
we were talking to and the ones who were
born here in the u.s
and this brings us of course to
immigration reform or the lack
thereof congress has tried for decades
to fix the problems it's failed every
time
president biden he called for
immigration reform last weekend at the
white house but it is not on the horizon
why is that
as in so many issues brent and reforms
president biden is trying to initiate
um the main hurdle for him is the
republican majority in congress
the democrats only have a razor thing
majority in both chambers
of congress um and uh legislative
measures like like immigration reform
for example can only be passed by
two-thirds
of the vote in the upper house this
means 60 votes in the senate
and this means of course that democrats
have to lobby a lot
and convince at least 10 republican
senators
to vote for a proposal that comes from
the democratic party from the democratic
party
and at the end this can only happen if
both sides agree to
to compromise as we have seen for
example during the infrastructure
debates
if they are also going to agree on an
immigration reform is doubtful
biden would have to give up for example
some aspects that republicans will not
accept like the path to a citizenship
for
almost 11 million undocumented
immigrants yeah you know every nation
has a right to defend its borders and it
has the right to control who enters and
leaves the country
that's the fundamental right of a
sovereign nation is that given enough
attention
in the discussion about the immigration
crisis at the border with mexico
that's a very interesting question brent
and this is actually one of the main
arguments
from the republican side of course every
country has that right
but the truth is that everything is also
connected political boundaries are not
real boundaries as we know and this is
perhaps something we can really learn
from the pandemic
the virus will not stop at the u.s
boundary for example it will just
trespass
every control um and what i want to
point out with this is that the
immigration problem is very complex
yes the u.s has the right to control its
border but it also has a duty to help
people and this is what initially
president biden meant by talking about a
more humane immigration policy
this is also what angela merkel in
germany promised in the year 2015
and indeed these countries also can help
to tackle the root causes in this case
the drug trafficking for example
is destroying democracies like the one
in honduras and the main market for
these drugs are
here in the united states and in europe
as well so these countries are not
completely disconnected from the reasons
that are forcing people to flee before
we run out of time i want to ask you
those naturalized
american citizens in your report they
came to the united states and became
citizens
the legal way if you will do they feel
that their
years of of patience and that their
stamina for all of the bureaucracy do
they do they feel like that is
adequately acknowledged
by the public
well i had the feeling that they don't
really care about that they knew
it wouldn't be a nice a an easy and nice
path to go
um in order to get the us citizenship
and they were just celebrating that
they are now american citizens um they
didn't really
have a problem with people knowing how
difficult the path
was and they were just proud really
proud and happy to be
part of this country now yeah it was
very very good for the soul if you will
to hear what they
were saying carolina chimoy reporting
tonight from washington carolina thank
you
you